- [Instructor] Have you ever
wanted to travel back in time?
Would you go meet your younger self?
Would you go and ride a dinosaur?
Or would you meticulously
create a timeline
of the Earth's
4.6-billion-year long history
based on major geological events?
Even though geologists
can't go back in time,
they've been able to do just that.
Their timeline is called
geologic timescale
and it breaks up all of Earth's history
into units called eons and eras.
And you may be wondering,
"How can we map out
what happened on Earth
billions of years ago?"
The answer is rocks.
Geologists look for clues
in sedimentary rock layers,
which we call strata.
The fossil record, which
are the remains of organisms
that have been preserved in rock layers
can give us glimpses of
creatures that breathe long ago.
Also, the difference
in mineral composition
in different rock layers
can tell geologists when a volcano erupted
or an asteroid hit.
But how did geologists
know when one rock layer
is older than another?
Well, when sedimentary rocks form,
they're deposited in layers,
one on top of the other.
So unless the layers are
disturbed or turned over,
the layers at the bottom
are always older than
the layers at the top.
Geologists call this rule
the Law of Superposition.
So if a geologist finds
a fossil of an ammonite
in a layer of rock above a
fossil of a Dunkleosteus,
the scientists would know
that the Dunkleosteus
is older than the ammonite.
This process is called relative dating
because it helps scientists
determine the relative ages
of rock layers and fossils.
But what does relative ages mean?
Let's say that I told you my friend Ava
is younger than her sister,
but older than her cat.
Then, I wouldn't be telling
you Ava's exact age,
but her relative age in relation
to her sister and her cat.
Let's take a look at another
example of relative ages,
this time, with rocks.
Imagine that one day you found a big rock
with many layers like this.
Because the rock is a sedimentary rock
and you remember the Law of Superposition,
you know that the layers
at the bottom are older
and you know that the
layers up here are younger.
But what about this
section of rock right here
that slices through the other layers?
Geologists would call this
section an igneous intrusion
since it was formed for
molten rock that has cooled.
This particular igneous intrusion
isn't clearly on top of
or below any of the
sedimentary rock layers.
So we can't use the Law
of Superposition here.
Luckily, geologists have
figured out another rule
called the law of
crosscutting relationships.
This rule says that when
two geologic features cross
or intersect,
the feature that cuts
through the other is younger,
and this makes sense
because you can't break
something before it even exists.
So since our igneous intrusion
cuts through the layers
of the sedimentary rock,
we know that it must be even
younger than the rock layers.
And what about this
fault or break over here?
Well, since it slice
through all the layers,
as well as the igneous rock,
the law of crosscutting relationships
tells us that the faults
must be the very youngest
geologic feature here.
Other pieces of evidence, like fossils,
could be used for relative dating.
For example, suppose a
geologist found a rock
containing fossils of extinct organisms
and another rock that contained
fossils of modern organisms.
The geologist could then deduce
that the rock with the
extinct organisms is older.
Certain kinds of fossils,
called index fossils,
are especially helpful when determining
the relative age of a rock.
Index fossils are fossils
that are only found
on a specific section of
the geologic timescale.
I always remember what an
index fossil is like this.
Just like I use my index finger
to point to give directions,
index fossils can point to
when on the geologic timescale
a rock was formed.
So if a geologist finds
the same index fossil
in rock layers in two different rocks,
they know that those rock
layers must have been formed
around the same time period,
but fossils aren't the only thing
that can help geologists figure
out a rock's relative age.
For example, if a geologist
found two rock layers
that contained evidence of
the same geologic event,
like a layer of ash from
a major volcanic eruption,
the geologists could deduce
that those rock layers
were made at the same time.
Relative dating is how
geologists figured out
that Stegosauruses were extinct
long before T-Rex's even existed.
It also helped them figure out
the first single cellular life
formed about 3.8 billion years ago
and the first multicellular life
formed about 600 million years ago,
and they figured out that
modern humans didn't even exist
until about 200,000 years ago,
which is right at the very end
of the geologic time scale.
In other words, it took a
really, really long time
for life to evolve into
what it looks like today.
We, humans, are very young
in the grand scheme of
the Earth's history.
Now, if you'll excuse me,
I'm gonna go saddle and
ride this Brontosaurus.
Let's go, ginger snap!
Hyah!